If you like well-written animated films with heart,
humor,
and great action...
Actually, scratch that.
If you are currently or have ever been alive,
then you probably love...
Experience a film that's got a little bit of everything,
from Silver Age comic book heroes
to a dark snapshot of a dying marriage,
slick, retro James Bond style
to a portrait of a mid-life crisis,
the warm glow of familial love
to the soul crushing modern day workplace.
Once again, you'll pay Pixar to yank your heart around like an emotional yo-yo.
[Sobbing]
I love this!
Meet the Parrs,
an Incredible-y dysfunctional family.
Violet is neglected,
Dash is hurting people for fun,
Bob is sneaking around behind his wife's back,
and Helen's in denial about his obvious lies.
"Have a great trip."
"Thanks, sweetie."
They've got more issues than a comic book shop,
and the only way to resolve them...
is to put on spandex and beat the crap out of some robots together.
"Ah, I love you."
Enter a world where the government has banned superheroes for fairly obvious reasons.
"You knocked down a building?!"
Now, Bob will have to adjust to not being able to punch people for a living
until he leaves in an opportunity to work for a killer robot company with a volcano lair.
"I'm in."
Dude, you were a hero for like decades!
You didn't see any red flags here?!
I'm starting to think this guy just wants to hurt people with no consequences!
Hey, heroes don't do that!
Unless you're Batman.
Batman totally does that.
Cower before one of the best supervillains of all time:
Syndrome,
a perfect prediction of today's entitled fanculture.
He's a nerd who loves something so much
that when it didn't live up to his expectations,
"You're not affiliated with me!"
he declared war on it.
And now, only the Incredibles can stop him from...
uh...
letting me buy rocket boots?
"I'll sell my inventions so that everyone can be superheroes."
Well, that's just great! Now how am I supposed to become a hero?!
Toxic waste covered reptiles aren't cheap, you know!
"Radical, radical, radical!"
Enjoy the best Fantastic 4 movie never made
that fixes all the flaws from those awful, awful films:
having its 4 heroes feel like a real family,
not treating their powers like a joke,
and making it so Mr. Fantastic is married to The Thing,
which is way hotter.
I mean, better.
I mean-
Dammit!
They're just both so T H I C C.
So cheer up, Logan,
and turn that frown upside-down, Rorschach,
'cause The Incredibles proves you don't have to be R-rated to be a violent, angsty superhero movie.
With a super high body count,
attempted suicide,
heroes threatening to murder innocent people,
"It'll be easy, like breaking a toothpick."
grown men shooting at little kids,
and little kids killing grown men,
you'll wonder what made Brad Bird fly into a homicidal rage between The Iron Giant and this movie.
Uh, probably box office.
"Money, money, money, money, money."
So, that whole cape rant that Edna goes on?
"No capes!"
Were those her designs that got all those heroes killed before she learned her lesson?
Because, uh, hoo, that's dark.